the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi everyone we're gonna get started so
today we're just another last day so
we're gonna split up and half is gonna
beat outside again
so hopefully bright coats if you haven't
you should start learning that's a good
thing the typical and then the other
half in the shop finishing up the
woodwork you did and then we're also
just gonna do some metalwork and PVC
work just so you get familiar with all
the tools in the shop for the pumps a
little bit I just wanted to mention
someone asked like is a foot pump always
better than a hand pump and the answer
is no there's a variety of reasons why
you might want a hand pump over a foot
pump one of them that's a little subtle
is that in some cultures it's not
acceptable for women to stand over
water's sources and so you can't use a
foot pump as a woman and so if the woman
needs to be able to do the work she has
to use a hand pump so there's many
places where foot pumps have not worked
because of that reason and hand pumps
have worked out great so there's a but
there's a lot of variety in what's gonna
work better where and why so yeah it's
not well you guys were calculating power
and that's what we're a little obsessed
about in this class that's not the only
thing you have to worry about is maximum
power
okay so addressing the rest of the pub
questions when you when you're actually
trying to decide what kind of pump to
implement in a specific site there are a
few things you need to take into
consideration first you need to figure
out how much water is gonna be used if
you're gonna pump a bucket of water a
day building a expensive rocker pump
doesn't really make sense and a hand
pump will do the trick
whereas if you're trying to get trying
to irrigate your entire field then maybe
a cement pump is a better alternative to
the hand pump because you want to sit
there pumping with your hand for hours
and hours and hours not being said the
other thing is that different pumps have
different can pump different amounts of
water and can pump over different
pressure heads
so the cement pump is a diaphragm pump
and I think it can pump about five to
seven meters deep only so it's not
really used to pump water from a low
water source like a borehole or
something like that because it just
won't be able to do that a little bit
about how it works is you have two
valves and then you have this sort of
it's called a diaphragm and then you
have another valve here and so what
happens is this thing can change
anywhere between this height and this
height when you step on it and so when
you when you step down you're
constricting the volume here and water
is gonna flow get pushed out of here
into this from your outlet and then when
you release it and you push up this
valve closes and then there's a pressure
difference in here or negative pressure
in here which will open this valve and
pull water in so it works pretty much
the same way with two one-way valves but
the thing is that you can't generate
that big pressure difference and that's
why you can't have you can't pump over
that or you can't pump that deep and so
that's another one of the considerations
you have to take into account I think
when you want to pump from bore holes or
something you want to get somewhere
around 50 ish meters deep I know the
hand pump that we went over the other
day pumps somewhere between 20 and 40
meters deep and the treadle pump which
you may have seen in other places it's
similar but instead of rocking back and
forth you lift up your legs up and down
kind of like this and it's the one that
IDE uses and it's mostly used for
irrigation of fields and that one that
one I know pumps only seven meters deep
and I lost my
cool yes
I think I've filtered put a filter at
the end of one of them kinda like about
that just collect
I've seen people use pumps with filters
on them generally larger pour filters
but the problem with that is you know we
have to replace the filter every so
often and you don't you know you don't
wanted an internal part of the pump
because he gets tedious to replace it
all the time but I've seen people put
like just cloth filters over the end to
get rid of turbidity great so it's
because a pump is pushing out a
relatively high pressure and filters
tend to work slowly it's rare that you
can just put a filter at the end
so typically while it would be great to
just have a point of use water
purification cleaning apart from like
turbidity factors it's hard to
and so yeah so those are I think the two
biggest questions from last week's lab
John if you have more questions about
last week's lab cool so some a little
bit about what we're gonna do today the
objectives are we're gonna try to learn
about how to get energy from solar
panels PV panels so you're gonna be
working with them we have one that's
this size and one that's maybe three
times the size of this but you're gonna
take these outside and hook them up and
then we're gonna learn about some of the
theory behind not actually how the PV
panel works we'll go into that later
but this is more about how to use the PV
panel and some applications that come
from that we're gonna learn how to hook
it up to a battery because that's one of
the most common uses I think and we're
gonna look at some of the design
considerations you have to take into
account when you look at designing a
solar system and so that's sort of one
half of the lab and the other half is
going to be working in the shop again
and you're gonna learn more about
fabrication techniques but this time
instead of working with wood we're going
to look at other materials like metal
and PVC and sheet metal cool so okay so
when you're trying to get energy humming
it's powerful this fun you basically
have your Sun and then you have the
surface of your earth and rays coming in
do any of you know how much best case
when the sun is shining there's no
clouds walking the way what the best
case power you can get from the Sun is
in watts per meter squared yeah it's
about a thousand
now at the beginning at the first class
we sat in we tried calculating the
average daily electrical consumption or
average electrical consumption per year
for people living in the developing
world and and based off of those numbers
we have you can approximate that people
in Nicaragua use about one kilowatt
hours a day and then people living in
Haiti use about 0.1 kilowatt hours of
electricity a day so if we're looking at
solar we're looking to power we're
looking to power all of these the one
kilowatt hour the point zero one
kilowatt hours that people are using in
the developing world using this energy
how much a surface area would we need to
harness the power so we can we can walk
through it right and we get
and then you know that a day has 24
hours so you can multiply that out
yeah it's true I'll get to that in a
second so you get about about that much
surface area where you need so if you
could ideally harness the power of the
Sun at this sufficient or at this much
power for 24 hours a day for one day you
would only need solar or you would only
need a collector that's 0.04 meter
squared which is pretty tiny which I
like which seems like a really good idea
but that a lot of consider like there
are a lot of reasons why this is not the
right way of figuring out how much power
you need so like you said for example
the Sun does how far down can you guys
read it again is it about here so yeah
so let's brainstorm some of these ideas
or some of these reasons
yes
it was indifferent how many floors yes
okay okay
max
that efficiency goes down even more as
the penalty
okay so let's start looking at some of
these and quantifying some of these
these constraints we have now so we
can't do this anymore
let's still work with these numbers as
ballpark's because I mean we're only
really concerned with order of magnitude
estimations really print this so so
efficiency of PV and Max you get about
thirty percent but I think that's sort
of the laboratory like cutting rate
technology that is really expensive with
commercially available PV it's more it's
somewhere between eight and eighteen
percent is what you're gonna get right
now yeah we're not gonna look at that
one yet so this one about how many hours
do you think should we approximate a son
to be up a day
okay so let's go
ten hours I think that's still a bit
high I think somewhere around eight is
better let's go eight hours and then
storage is also a big factor that you
have a huge amount of energy lost in
storage as well there's like this is why
I want this is one of the reasons why
just energy is a problem because we have
no really good way of storing it yet so
generally when you are trying to get
power from your solar panel you're gonna
try to charge something with it like
like a battery and when charge a battery
with it you have built-in losses and the
efficiency of transferring power from a
solar panel to a battery without using
any sort of volt or like voltage
regulation or anything because that has
voltage that has energy lost to is about
75%
and so now that you've stored your
energy what sort of occations are gonna
try to power off of this battery yeah
and what kind of power do small
appliances take are you gonna a see so
you have to convert this because when
you still have power stored in a battery
it's stored as DC so you have to convert
it to AC again so you have this DC to AC
conversion which also has a lost
inefficiency and then we can say that's
about 75% - it varies a lot depending on
how expensive if your your inverter is
and like how you're matching your loads
with that inverter so it goes anywhere
between like 50 and 90 percent I'd say
but 70 for picking or 75% is reasonable
so now that we have all of these numbers
we can look at we can reevaluate our our
calculations so we have one kilowatt
hours still for Nicaragua and now we're
dividing it by
times 0.75
do I think we want him to denominator
space and let's just say that that's 10%
sure
okay and does someone have a calculator
and wanted to do this I can do it on my
computer - that's right
I think I think that's in the its
kilowatts divided by that so it's
actually going to be 2.7 whatever it's
gonna be about three meters squared yeah
which is suddenly a lot larger than what
we had before and this is still assuming
that this is going to be best-case
scenario and so if we assume that the
Sun is gonna be shining bright every day
I'm gonna have to have a solar panel at
least three meters squared or three
tours and then we have to think about
other things too when we're dealing with
PV usage like what is the power being
used for and how reliable does it need
to be so what are what are some places
we could think about installing solar
panels were wouldn't need to be reliable
and it would need to be very reliable
okay
I guess in the non reliable maybe a home
where you don't have you know if you
ever house it's not using refrigeration
and they're using lighting if they don't
have electricity for one day or
something like that it's not the end of
the world but but when you're when
you're looking at designing a solar
photovoltaic system for a community
partner you need to like you need to be
asking these sorts of questions like how
long can you go without power for a
hospital if you can't go a day without
power what do you do if there's no Sun
for a week if it's cloudy you can you
can't have people who are on technology
you can't have like you just can't have
that for the hospital so you need to
build a more robust system that can draw
more power and store it better
whereas for housing maybe a couple days
if not you can afford to go without
electricity for a couple of days
so yeah and then does anyone know what
the cost of photovoltaics is as well
you
yeah when we were looking this up we
found a pretty big range for how
expensive they were I think some most of
the sources were saying it was around
three to five dollars for the cheapest
PV we could find but it's still on that
order for what and so I guess the thing
you should take away from this is a lot
of times people look at lighting and
just say or electricity and just assume
that solar is like a miraculous solution
that's gonna solve everything and you
really don't want to think about it is
that you want to actually think about
all of the considerations that go into
creating a system so now I'll show you
this is this is like this is a solar
panel that we got for D lab we have two
of these basically you have a positive
and ground coming out of it so you can
hook it up to a load but if you want to
hook it up to a battery you have to
somehow regulate the voltage before
you're doing that because if you plug
this in directly to well what'll happen
if you're trying to charge a 12-volt
battery and the solar panels outputting
about twenty volts and it's a lead-acid
battery like a car battery that you're
trying to charge
you're fine yeah but if I explode I
think if you drive too much voltage or
shoot through a car battery you're gonna
end up producing hydrogen and oxygen as
byproducts and it's very flammable and
if there's a spark then it explodes what
about the opposite case where your solar
panel is outputting eight volts or
something like that or six volts and
your battery is trying to take 12 volts
yeah more so than that though not that
it's not only in a charge but your solar
panel is gonna discharge your battery so
you're gonna do the opposite so you need
to build in some sort of regulation for
it you're gonna have to have a voltage
regulator that makes sure that you're
outputting the right amount of voltage
or and then you also need to make sure
that you have a diode in there somewhere
so that electricity doesn't backflow and
drain the battery luckily for us instead
of having to design and build all of
these things there companies are good
for us so we have a couple of these
solar controllers and so they have this
stuff built in so you can hook a solar
panel up to two ends of this and your
battery up to the other two and then you
can charge a battery from that and this
is just there are two different ones
this one takes this one you can put a
load directly onto as well and the last
thing I was going to talk about are
resistors and potentiometers do you guys
know how you guys seen potentiometers
before okay yeah so what a potentiometer
is is it's a variable resistor and so
this thing is a resistant this thing has
uniform resistance that changes linearly
with how you turn this so if you're over
here you're you're effectively have a
resistor that's this long and then when
you open it to this far you get a
resistor that's twice as long and so you
can change the resistance anywhere from
zero to this one's rated at 500 ohms
it's kind of like what we did the other
day with the resistance the resistance
is equal to Rho L over a so you're just
changing L and getting more resistance
so the way you use these you're gonna
use them later on in the lab so I just
thought I'd explain it right now is you
could hook up to these two terminals if
you hook up across here you're just
gonna get the full 500 ohms and if so if
you hook up to here as you sweep this
across it'll your resistance will go up
and when you guys are doing the lab
remember I wrote it as a node and I'll
explain it again there but remember that
when you're measuring the resistance of
this you want to disconnect it from the
solar panel because if you don't you're
gonna fry the voltmeter and it's not
yeah we don't want you to fry voltmeters
because they're expensive and we only
have two right now so do you have any
questions about what we talked about
right now okay so we could split into
two groups
okay